continúa el complejo trabajo de Los
socorristas que buscan sacarlos
cadáveres atrapados en el glaciar de la
marmorada en el norte de Italia en donde
el domingo pasado una avalancha de hielo
provocó la muerte de al menos 8 personas
en los alpes italianos por razones de
seguridad en los equipos de Socorro no
pueden subir al pie del glaciar se temen
nuevas avalanchas razón por la cual la
búsqueda de las víctimas se hace a
través de drones con cámaras térmicas y
un helicóptero con a bordo un sistema
capaz de interceptar las señales de los
teléfonos celulares el jefe del gobierno
italiano el señor Mario draghi ha
señalado al cambio climático como la
principal causa de la tragedia la nieve
en este glaciar se ha consumido
prematuramente consecuencia de una ola
de calor que está azotando la Península
italiana en los últimos días en las
temperaturas en las principales ciudades
del país han pasado los 40 grados
centígrados y una sequía sin precedentes
ha obligado a varias regiones a iniciar
racionamientos de agua los expertos
glaciólogos advierten que las avalanchas
en los glaciares italianos se repetirán
si no se pone un freno radical al
calentamiento glo